great as you join the session please let
us know where you're joining from city
state country if you're outside the U.S
and we'll be starting in just another
two minutes
hope everybody had a great Fourth of
July holiday
yeah
we're looking forward to getting this
webinar started our
trainer raghvender will be joining us
shortly
green time yeah you
have somebody from Los Angeles that's
the first one
welcome Ayanna
who's here's joining from Livermore
God happens to be in the area I live in
I mean
Contra Costa County
east of San Francisco
across the bay
Oak Park
anyone else
welcome Stephen joining from the UK
all right
all right and let's get started
there we go
foreign
to our program preview uh this is
a preview of how to get started in web
development the coding boot camp from
Caltech Center for technology and
management education
my name is Stuart Creek I'm with simply
learn we're the delivery partner with
Caltech for this program
and join shortly
bye
one of our expert trainers
so throughout the program please put
your questions in the Q a box as they
come to you we'll take those toward the
end of the session the session is being
recorded so you should expect a
follow-up email with a link to the
recording and also information about
your bonus offer for attending today's
session live
and
uh put in your name if you wish
to
or this particular webinar so again keep
an eye out in the post webinar survey
put your name in there for
this webinar proof of attendance
so just to set the stage for you we'll
be talking about you I'll be asking a
few questions along the way keep an eye
out for the poll questions
um we'll also be talking about full
stack coding careers what the field
entails and what are your opportunities
in it and we'll talk about how this
particular boot camp prepares you
tour a career in that field we'll share
with you some of the learner outcomes
that people have experienced and I'll go
over the enrollment steps and the bonus
buffer that I mentioned how to claim
that and we'll get to your questions and
answers for the end of the session
so first I'd like to go with a poll
question this is pretty basic
how much experience do you have are you
still studying for your degree are you
in the workforce how long have you been
in the workforce we'll just leave this
open for about another 15 seconds
foreign
so please hit that submit button
and three two one
third of our audience today are folks
who are still in school
the rest of you I have
work experience up to including the
third of our audience who have more than
five years so
we'll
discuss how this program can help
all of you
just want to introduce simply learn for
those of you who don't know we simply
learned is the number one online boot
camp in the world for digital skills for
the digital economy
um we have been doing this for 13 years
and we've helped five million people
around the world in 150 countries
gain those digital skills upskilled
themselves
we deliver all of our programs online so
that they're available to you wherever
you have a web browser
our programs use a blended learning
model where many of them include live
instruction and so it's not just a
matter of watching videos but it's a
full integrated learning experience
we'll talk about that a bit more
and our vendor joins let him introduce
himself more fully but just to give you
a background he is a full stack
development engineer
he has more than nine years of
experience as a developer you
supervises and runs a group of
Developers
so he has experience in that management
area as well and he's been doing
um
construction with us for more than four
years
are doing a lot of different
courses programs and batches for us so
very pleased about that
but let's talk a little bit about
careers
full stack coating
the full stock development is how the
web gets built today
you can see I've been around for quite a
while and
in the days predating
the web built
applications for
mainframe computers mini computers
even for personal computers that were
intended to stand alone
intended to be fully independent and
fully self-contained and
you would do that through a waterfall
method where
somebody would work with the client or
with the
end users proxy to Define
what a program was supposed to do
fully specify it out and then you would
go through a series of stages to develop
specification develop the design to code
the modules to integrate to test and
then to deliver
um
and that meant by the end of the process
you probably had code that was
out of date for what the market needed
back then the market was moving slower
so that was less of a problem
than it is today but
today full stack development
web environment
means that you have to have
agile
development process
supports solutions that are scalable so
that
application can handle the Peaks and
valleys of demand can handle
creasing
database sizes as something becomes more
popular or as more data becomes
available for your solution this is
especially important in the era of AI
where
the more data you have the better
machine learning model can
teach itself and so you need solutions
that can be scaled in terms of storage
in terms of compute power
terms of reach
and you need to be able to do that using
open source tools so that you are not
strictly dependent on
particular vendors idiosyncrasies
you want to be able to adapt as things
change in the industry
and you need to understand how the stack
is built so that you understand how each
level becomes optimized for its function
um
the wonderful thing about
the way whole stack development has done
today is development tasks can be
divided among team members in many
different ways
so you can
have people who specialize in the front
end people who specialize in back-end
development people specialize
in database management
so each of those parts can have
Specialists but they all have to be able
to work together so it's a full stack
developer it's important for you to
understand all of the levels of the
stack
be able to communicate even if you are
just working on one level
so that all makes sense
I want to point out that there are
27.7 million software developers
worldwide
um it's a
very large industry segment there's a 13
growth rate in software employment
United States according to the Bureau of
Labor Statistics of the US government
and so the opportunities continue to
expand they expanded dramatically after
the pandemic during the pandemic
so many companies had to shift to
digital presence where they didn't think
they needed one before
we had been experiencing this digital
transformation for many years but now
with the pandemic people were being
asked to work from home
people were being asked to do business
in a online non-contact mode
so need for software Developers
spiked
so this is a great field because we're
not going backward in that direction
a lot of different rules as I mentioned
you can
start off as a full stack developer you
might be assigned to front and back-end
um as you progress
skills you might become a full stack
engineer
working more at
infrastructure in addition to
application development
you might gain experience
skills and become a team leader
and all of these
different paths for growth for
specialization are open to you if you
have the right skill set and background
so
as I mentioned demand is soaring
salaries are keeping Pace
um
full stack developer
somebody who starts in the career little
experience and these are average U.S
wide salaries
The Glassdoor so you might at an entry
level job at around 75k
then you move into with some experience
you can move up in that role on up
to 144. if you gain the experience and
skills needed to become a full stack
engineer your salary range increases
potential increases and if you become a
lead increase
this is even more so you can make a good
living
up into the low to mid six figures
in this area
it's a good place to build a career
forgive me
one moment while I check
okay
all right
um so excuse me for that
examples of companies hiring again going
to Glassdoor you can take a look across
the board
number of companies hiring these are
some of the biggest names
see that they fall across different
categories not just in technology
but also in healthcare and Banking and
services
so these are all
places that have openings they're
listening now
it turns out that of course
you can find listings for software
developers almost across every industry
almost across every size of company
and it's a really
broad-based
career opportunity
so I know that you're all interested
here in potential for this career
becoming a software developer
what has stopped you from
enrolling in a course of this type
up until now what are the things that
you've looked for that you haven't found
lacking in other offerings
because you can't find a comprehensive
curriculum or is it because you don't
feel confident you get practical
experience examples to take with you
from the course
eyes because you don't like to learn
just from watching videos
or is it because finding time to learn
is a
I'll just leave this open for another 10
seconds
and you can choose more than one answer
I'm going to close the poll in five
seconds so hit the submit button please
three
two
one
pull
and so the prime concern people have in
our audience today is finding time in
your
schedule to a course like this
in order to be able to
fit it in with your life as a working
professional or as a student
and
the other two main reasons are
finding practical experience coming out
of the program with examples in your
portfolio
and
finding a program that has a
comprehensive
skill set
let's
move on and address that
momentarily hold on
there we go
all right
so ideally you'd find a program that has
a curriculum that lines up with what
people are looking for in the industry
to hire
well I look one look for
curriculum that matches what companies
say they need
you also want
uh
course a program that gives you the
opportunity to do
projects
engage in labs and build out your
portfolio with examples of your
experience so that you have something to
show to potential employers or to your
current employer for promotion that type
of thing demonstrating your actual
skills
you also want to find a program
for those of you who don't work well
with just watching videos you want a
program where you have a live instructor
who can take you through the exercises
answer your questions clear up any kind
of concerns keep you from going down
rabbit holes and that type of thing
and also the opportunity to interact
interact with the other students who are
learning the program at the same time as
you because that that kind of mutual
support
very helpful
and finally and most importantly for a
lot of you is finding a program that
will allow you to do this without
interfering with your work and personal
life so
we're going to talk about the
Caltech coding boot camp
cutting boot camp is designed by the
Caltech Center for technology and
management education
to get you up to speed in full stack
development in six months so it's a
intensive rapid program
but it requires you only to devote about
10 hours a week
there's live classes every week about
eight hours worth of live classes
those are at scheduled times and you
pick uh weekend typically weekends
mornings on Saturdays and Sundays and
outside of those sessions
you can do the work anytime you want
because this is delivered on a platform
that's online available 24 7 anywhere
that you have a web browser
so anytime you have your desktop or
laptop available to you
you can do the coursework you can watch
some of the prep materials and read some
of the materials on your tablet or
mobile device
so it's very flexible in that respect
but it does include online live virtual
classrooms where you interact with the
trainers with the instructors and with
your peers
and includes a sandboxed live virtual
environment where you can do your
projects
do your Labs use the tools that you're
learning
create actual projects
code examples that go into your
portfolio
so it's designed to help you become
job ready
the end of the process Caltech issues
you a certificate that a tests that you
have met the requirements of the program
that they can vouch for your new set of
skills
you also get uh certificates within the
program for each of the courses as uh
proof of your accomplishment at each
step
you get your git portfolio that allows
you to show
what you've accomplished and what you've
built and demonstrate that you have a
link to other people who want to look at
your body of work for evaluating you for
a new position or promotion
you can also receive up to 17 continuing
education units from Caltech if you're
in a
a job that requires you to provide
continuing education
proof
can you develop your skills
those CEUs for completing this program
you get membership in the Caltech Circle
which is a virtual Alumni Association
for people who've taken the Caltech ctme
programs
and Caltech will let you network with
your peers who've taken programs they'll
also get a chance to see exclusive
events that they run for the Caltech
Circle
and you'll be recognized at an online
convocation so you'll have a chance to
invite your friends and family to you
recognize by name or completing this
program
and
just to mention Caltech I think most
people are familiar with Caltech as an
institution
Caltech been around for over 130 years
despite its name it is not part of the
University of California system or the
Caltech State University system
uh it's a private Institution
focused on Graduate Studies and research
they don't take in a lot of
undergraduates
they primarily focus on helping people
earn phds
and do Advanced cutting-edge research in
a number of different fields
for example Caltech has the jet
propulsion laboratory for NASA where
Caltech scientists and engineers
design and build deep space probes that
will do different missions once launched
into space so
actually see the
satellites and probes being built there
prepared for delivery to NASA for launch
um it's a pretty amazing place it's one
of the highest concentrations of
brilliant people in the world if you've
watched The Big Bang Theory television
show
you know that they chose Caltech as the
setting because Caltech really does have
a lot of very very very brilliant people
a number of people who
got Nobel prizes for the work they did
at Caltech and a number of people who
got Nobel prizes for work they did
elsewhere have come to Caltech to
continue their research so
one of the top five universities
worldwide almost every ranking
and having that name on your
resume is going to be something that
people will recognize and respect
so this program is pretty wide open
you can have just a high school diploma
as long as you're 18 years of age or
older
do you not have to have a college degree
to start this program
you don't have to come in with work
experience or a programming background
this is intended to take you from a very
raw background and
give you the skills that you need to be
a successful full stack developer
if you have work experience if you are a
developer the more advanced courses in
the curriculum will help you increase
those skills gain more
capability
and so
this is a program that can help people
at all ranges in their career experience
let's talk about how this program helps
you
program is designed to build your
experience your capabilities step by
step start with an introduction
induction session that gets you ready
teaches you how to use the online
platform orients you to your curriculum
shows you how to enroll in your class
sessions and how to access them how to
use the lab environment your project
once you've gone through that
start in
basic core module of planning and user
interface design
so this is how you look at the
application Level of the stack how you
look at how users will use the
applications You're Building
then from that you look at the back end
database development how
you have to support that front end that
you designed and build the back-end
processing and data management
then move on into API endpoints and
communication for the communication
between levels of the stack or into
other systems
finally integration and deployment
all of this builds up to your Capstone
project in which you select
industry-based
Challenge and come up with
Your solution that challenge
so that's a several week project where
you're mentored by your instructor but
you build an independent solution for
this
problem you also have the elective
looted in the price of the program you
can take as many of the master classes
As You Wish where you hear from
Caltech instructors about
new experiences new developments in the
industry
and that adds a lot of richness to this
program as well
so I mentioned the Capstone project I
just want to go in a little more depth
Capstone project is where you take all
of the skills that you have learned in
the course of the program
and you integrate those into a final
project based on a real world
industry-based challenge
pick from several different options
then you design the solution you build a
full stack implementation that solves
that problem delivers that requirement
again you meet with your instructor
weekly over several weeks of developing
this project so that they can help you
make avoid any dead ends or rabbit holes
but this is something that you design
independently
individual learner creates an individual
Capstone project which is turned in for
evaluation for getting your certificate
so it becomes
essentially your final exam
it also becomes a great artifact for
your portfolio
you can say this is a problem I solved
here's how I
approach the problem design the solution
and implemented it
so this allows you to build your git
portfolio where you create your own page
this is where you would be able to give
a link to this portfolio and show off
what you've accomplished within this
program but you can also
add to it with independent projects that
you do
outside of the program or afterward
a great resource for you to be able to
show off your body of work
demonstrate your skills
so simple learn
as the delivery partner offers a kind of
ecosystem of support for you
program manager who interacts with
Caltech and make sure that we're
delivering the program to their
standards of course is one of the
aspects you also have a cohort manager
so when you enroll in the program you'll
enroll with a number of people on the
same date same time and you'll uh be
part of that cohort as you go through
the program
we have someone assigned help Mentor all
of you and make sure that you
keep up with the pace of the program
of course the instructors in each course
are going to help you succeed in that
course as well as your peers your
learning teams people that you'll
interact with who are fellow members of
your cohort fellow learners
finally the design of the curriculum and
the resources
tended to support your success by taking
you through in an understandable and
logical way so
all of this together forms a kind of
ecosystem of support that helps
ensure that you have the best chance of
succeeding
so
okay we have a message from gusha who
does need to leave but we will be
sending out a recording link to this
session so you'll be able to review this
information now Alexandra hasn't joined
us yet so we don't have the live tour
learning environment but I do want to
tell you how it works
um The Learning environment allows you
to manage your curriculum see all the
courses
that comprise the program gives you your
status report on how far you've
accomplished
to the courses
um gives you the ability to see your
class schedule manage your calendar
enroll in and then join the live virtual
classrooms where your instructor will
take you through exercises on the live
lab environment
typically the class will include some
period where the instructor explains the
concept to you and then asks you to fire
up your learning lab
do the exercise along with him or her so
that you can see how it works
get a feel for how the tools work how
the concepts work what you're learning
you have ability to take your tests and
assessments independently each course
will list what the requirements are in
terms of how many classes you must
complete and what projects and
time tests you have to complete in order
to earn the certificate for that course
and then move on to the next course
within the mod program
again Capstone project
one of defined as one of the courses in
your curriculum and uh
do it in the same way again but more
independent
work and study and more independent
thought goes into your solution for that
Capstone
along the way you get to see your
progress you get to unlock certificates
for each stage in the program
and
uh
you finally unlock your complete program
certificate once your Capstone project
has been reviewed and accepted
you have support tools along the way
which include a community
where you can post threads about issues
questions problems you have you can
monitor information from your
instructors from your classmates
you also have a help desk available 24
7. so if you happen to be working on a
project at three o'clock in the morning
and reach something that puzzles you you
can reach out to the help desk get an
answer either from the knowledge base or
from a live human being
and so the program keeps tracking your
progress it'll send you prompts and
reminders
and keep you going
along the right schedule so
this is all designed it's part of the
support system to help you succeed
now again the program
curriculum is developed by Caltech
Center for technology and management
education
Rick Hefner is the executive director
he's been involved in
industry and Academia for 40 years
and he works with a number of companies
who've come to Caltech over the years
and said we want our employees to be
able to do some of the things that your
researchers and
developers do and so
Caltech has designed this
program through its Center for
technology and management education
precisely to transfer those skills and
that knowledge to Industry Dave starro
is the advising Professor who supervises
specifically the software course and
he's not just an academic but he's been
an entrepreneur
bring that same industry perspective to
the program so
this is a program designed to help you
get ready to work in the industry
we'll talk about some of the learner
outcomes
a couple of testimonials and I'll share
with you in a little bit the link to our
program page
you'll be able to see a number of these
other testimonials but Andrea uh really
succeeded from
the way the program was designed the way
that industry experts provided live
instruction along with the 24x7
availability of the platform so that
combined gave her the
ability to complete the program succeed
same thing with Kamar who
completed the program
learned a lot and as I said
was able to to comprehend all the
aspects of full stack development back
end to front end to the devops cycle
um
we hope that we can add you to this
roster of
learners
one of the unique things that simply
learn brings to this program is a career
assist service for six months after
the completion of your certificate so
once you've received your certificate
you have six more months of access to
the talenting job portal
kind of confidential
way to look for new jobs without
revealing your search to your employer
um they also provide
a couple of very valuable Services
resume review and rewrite which allows
you to get professional help
to
adapt your resume to the new environment
where
AI Bots will see it before it is ever
shown to a human being
your resume has to be a
compatible with that process and still
be attractive to people who will see it
after the AI bot
gives it a thumbs up so that's an art
form that the professional writer will
help you with and similarly the
one-on-one interview service will help
you get actual practice with the human
being for all the different kinds of
interviews that you're going to have to
do get a new job or a promotion from the
phone screen to the
skills interviews that will cover your
capabilities to the management
compatibility interviews showing that
you're a team player that you fit with
the culture of the company that type
each of those interview Styles requires
you to present a different aspect of
yourself and the ability to practice
each of them with an actual person a
really valuable part of this job as a
service again not a job placement
service not a job guarantee service but
a set of services that will help you in
your job search
so at this point I want to ask a
question based on what I've shared with
you so far are you interested
in
this program
I'll leave this open for about 20
seconds
and we'll be sharing more information
about the enrollment process cost that
type of thing shortly
but so far
here's the result
everyone who answered said yes so that's
excellent we'll
move on
so the program fees are flat U.S eight
thousand dollars
um
you can finance that over time at 705
dollars a month
which works out to be a 12 month payment
plan
and
email us at ask us at simplylearn.net
because you will receive a bonus
discount offer
from these fees from attending this
webinar today
so reach out to us and ask us at
simplylearn.net
into
our chat here
and
they'll be able to tell you what the
oops amount of this
uh
I don't know where to go there we go
mobile will tell you what the amount of
the
county is
oh sorry
got it that's now in the chat that email
address
let's talk about the timing
um the claim for that discount comes if
you enroll in our next
cohort so you ask us at silverlearn.net
is where you send in your application we
review your qualifications again
very open
there's not a lot of prerequisites you
have to
satisfy
if you do satisfy those and show the
aptitude and desire for this program
will send you an admission offer
and the next induction session happens
August 14th which is the day classes
start it happens to fall on the same day
in this case usually the induction
sessions can be done a bit in advance
in case you can do the induction session
just before you start the classes
and so if you want to join the August
cohort
month from now
you should contact us quickly because
the number of people we can introduce
into each cohort is limited
and only have about 25 to 30 people
in each cohort in order for the
instructors to be able to give
sufficient attention to each
so the seats are limited do reach out to
us
that leads to my next question
which is how soon
if you're one of the people who said yes
how soon would you like to start are you
interested in the August cohort
are you looking
a few months after that or are you
looking further down the road so
I'll leave this open just for another
five seconds four three
two one
K and
looks like a lot of you are looking at
that August cohort being able to claim
the bonus discount so please do email us
if you're looking further down the road
are you interested in the program not
ready to start quite yet also email us
at ins ask us at simplylearn.net because
what that'll do is allow us to keep you
informed about future cohorts as well as
answer any
lingering questions you may have before
enrolling so
please do Reach Out
oops
I'm going to go into the Q a we don't
have a lot of questions
but I do want to answer the one question
are there prerequisites for the boot
camp so Anil
um yeah we covered that with the
prerequisites are very simple you need
to have
a high school diploma or the equivalent
you need to be 18 years of age
and you need to have a desire
um commitment to doing this program and
getting qualified as a full stack
developer because this is not
um a minor undertaking we're asking you
to make an investment of both your funds
and your time
be available
every weekend for six months
um you won't have to be in classes every
single weekend but you should plan your
future schedule that way so that
you can eat the attendance requirements
of each course so that you have the time
available to do your
homework in labs and projects
have to be able to commit to doing that
final Capstone project all of this is uh
not a
an idol undertaking
this is something that you need to um
think about and the prerequisites in
this particular case really fall more on
you than on us evaluating
oh
that's
the answer to that we have a question
from the chat
um
use my eyes
or edware
question can I write a python algorithm
using this class
so in this course you are going to learn
um how to develop algorithms
data structures
um
you'll also
learn about database management you also
learn about
different front end and back-end
scripting uh less about python
more about
um
Java JavaScript C sharp
u-sharp Sharp
um
so all of those types of things are
part of the program
um
less about python
I hope that helps
and do we get a free trial of the class
I can point you to webinars we've done
which give you a free example of what
the class looks like
this is not a
actual free trial but it's a kind of a
flavor of what the class is like
um but yes with respect to that
you can see what the classes look like
from the
uh learner's slide
um
again not a free trial
do we have any other questions coming in
I don't see any
where would I go for python for Caltech
uh
so Caltech and simply learn offer
several programs that go deeper into
Python and R for database for data
science rather
so you can
contact us ask us at simplylearn.net or
go to our website and take a look at
Caltech
data science boot camp aim El boot camp
those are also available
through our website I'm going to put
into the chat right now
the URL for the program page for this
program along with again
our
email address
and
this point quick question for those of
you who are interested in this program
would you like us to reach out to you
directly
and I'll just leave this open for 10
seconds
if you answer yes we will contact you
directly
about the program
all right and I'll end the poll
and 40 said yes so expect uh to hear
from us
and with that
I want to
say thank you to everyone who attended
today
we appreciate your being here my
apologies for uh reg vendor's absence
um
and
again reach out to us you can contact us
with questions
and use the QR code to get to our web
page
we want to welcome you into the Caltech
and simply learn learning community and
look forward to seeing you there
thank you and that ends our webinar for
today